hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem time based key
value store and this is one of my
favorite problems honestly on all of
late code because there's not a lot of
fancy tricks involved you can really
logically uh you know dig your way
through this problem so you can go ahead
and read through this description if you
want but i'm going to go ahead and jump
straight into the explanation because i
think this is best understood by
actually going through an example so our
whole objective here is to design a key
value store so it's kind of like a hash
map we're gonna have some key value and
then we're gonna have a value associated
with that key but we're actually not
just gonna have a single value we're
gonna have a list of values
uh so plural so it'll be a list and in
that list we're gonna have a pair of
values so it's not just gonna be a
single value each value is gonna have a
time stamp associated with it so for an
example we can have a key value of let's
say foo and we would have a list of
values associated with that and one of
the values the pair of values right
because we're going to have a value and
then a time so
the value let's say is going to be bar
it's a string in this case and the time
stamp associated with it let's just say
in this case the example it's going to
be integer so let's just say it's 1 in
this case and then we could have a
second value right associated with it as
well and that will have its own
timestamp as well right so basically
it's going to be a list of values the
and the values themselves are going to
be pairs a value and then a timestamp
associated with that so it's not super
complicated but the main operations that
we're going to support are actually
pretty simple just two operations
actually three if you count the
constructor so yes we're going to have a
you know constructor because it's an
object that we're designing a class and
the two operations we want to support on
this key value store are going to be set
and get which is pretty straightforward
that's what we would expect so let's
just go through this example and i think
the problem will actually make a lot of
sense to you so the first operation we
have is a set operation the key is going
to be the first value foo the value is
going to be bar and the time stamp
associated with it is going to be 1. so
let's put the first value here it's
going to be bar
and the time associated with it is just
one and now we get the second operation
get what are we getting we're getting
the key uh associated with foo
and the the second parameter in our get
operation is actually going to be the
time stamp so when we do a get operation
normally on a hashmap we just need a key
but in this case we need two values the
key and the timestamp right because we
know that for a single key it's not
enough to identify a value right because
there could be multiple values over here
we need the time stamp to identify the
actual value in this case we were given
a key value of foo and we were given a
timestamp of one right you can see up
above yeah it's one and by the way in
case i didn't mention we're actually
going to be implementing this this
entire key value store with a hash map
so
you know the keys are just going to be
normal
hash map keys and the value in this hash
map is going to be a list of values
with you know this schema right this the
list of values are going to be pairs so
when we use the key in the hashmap we're
going to get a list of values right in
this case this list only has one pair of
values bar is that value and remember we
were given a timestamp of one so in this
list we're gonna basically iterate
through the list to find the pair that
has a timestamp of one in this case we
did find it right it does exist so then
we can take this and uh the thing i
think we're returning is just the value
itself so we can return bar and you can
see up above that's what they ended up
returning for this operation so we did
our first get operation that's great now
let's do our second get operation in
this case we're given this pair we're
given the key is going to be foo so
right we can go to the same list and the
timestamp is actually three in this case
but if you scan through the entire list
that we have here you can see that none
of these have a timestamp of three
associated with them so what does that
mean are we just gonna return null in
this case no because remember what we're
doing here we're designing a key
a key value store based on time so we
set this value at time one now it's time
three so the way this problem wants us
to handle the timing is basically if you
don't find an exact match in our in our
key value store then just return the
most recent one so in this case we're
doing
the time is three right just return the
most recent one and by recent they mean
the the closest value to three that's
less than three so for example there's
only a single value here right so in
this case we only have a single one and
the time with that is one so of course
one is going to be the closest to three
but what if instead we had something
like four
four is close to three but it's greater
than three so that's not allowed we
wanna find the closest timestamp that's
less than three now if we had multiple
if we had another bar here or some other
value and the time associated with that
is two then in that case uh which of
these two would we want to return we
would want to return this one even
though the value is the exact same but
we'd want to return this one because it
has a closer time to the three but in
this case we only had a single value so
we're just going to return bar again and
you can see in the explanation and the
output that is the correct value so we
return bar in this case okay so just
cleaning up what we've already done so
far but now we're at a second set
operation the values associated with
this set are well the key is foo so same
you know slot we're gonna go over here
and the value in this case is bar two
pretty simple and the time associated
with it is four so that's the timestamp
uh bar two and the time is four and by
the way the set operation that we're
doing is always going to be a constant
time operation big o of one right
because the you know so finding the key
is an o of one operation because we're
using a hash map and then uh you know
this list of values is gonna be a list
and every time we add a value to this
list we're always going to add it to the
end of the list so we can do that in big
o of one time
so not too bad but where things get
tricky uh now that we're done with the
second set operation where things get
tricky is when we get to the get
operation so now we're at another get
operation the key is foo and the time
stamp is four so we're going to go to
the same slot here and then now that we
actually have more values you're
probably getting at what the bottleneck
is so in this case the timestamp is 4.
so we want to look in this list we want
to look for an exact match and if we
can't find an exact match we want to
find the closest value that's less than
4. and how exactly are we going to be
doing that if we just do a linear scan
through the array worst case it's going
to be linear time now that's really not
that bad but the question is can we do
any better well obviously very few
algorithms are better than big o of n
one of the algorithms that's better than
big o of n is binary search which we
know runs in log n time that's
definitely an improvement over big o of
n but that would require that our values
are sorted but what exactly do these
values have to be sorted by do they have
to be sorted by the value or by the time
stamp well since we're searching for an
exact match with the time stamp these
have to be sorted by the timestamp so
again not too bad what are we supposed
to do though are we supposed to sort
this every single time we want to do a
get operation that's not going to make
things any better because if we have to
sort the time complexity is not going to
be log n and it's not even going to be n
either it's going to be n log n so
that's not an improvement at all and so
this is the part where we kind of have
to be smart let's go down and read the
problem carefully if you scroll all the
way down and read the fine print you can
see that all the time stamps every time
we we set a value the timestamp is going
to be in increasing order strictly in
increasing order so how does this help
us well basically it means if we have a
list here and every time we set a value
we just add it to the end of the list
then the list is actually going to be
sorted by the timestamp by default so
it's already in sorted order so that's
why
we don't have to sort it again we
actually can just run a binary search
that's really good for us but what if
you you know what if you didn't really
read the fine print well the way this
problem is set up i think it's kind of
intuitive that if you are in a real
interview the best question would be to
ask every time we set a value is it you
know is the timestamp gonna be in
ascending order because you know the way
a set operation would work in real life
is you would use the the current time
that you know the current time that
you're setting the value and you know as
most of us know time really just flows
in one direction so it makes sense that
these
you know the list that we're setting
would already be in sorted order but
again that's kind of why i like this
question because even if you don't read
the fine print you might think to
yourself are the set operations going to
be in sorted order and that would be a
really good question to ask in a real
interview so in this case we would want
to run binary search which would be
login time so that just means that the
get operation worst case is going to be
a log in operation and by the way if
we're looking for the key value 4 we
know that it exists so this is what we
would end up returning we would return
bar 2 and you can see that's exactly
what they did return in the output so
we're done with another operation let's
cross this out and let's do our last
operation the get operation in this case
the key is foo so again over here and
the time stamp is five so again we're
gonna run binary search right we're
looking for an exact match of five and
if we can't find the five what's the
closest thing that we can get that's
less than five well in this case it's
four so the value of that is bar two so
again we'd return bar two so that's kind
of what i wanted to cover with this
problem of course we just had a single
key but you know this problem wouldn't
be much different if we had a second key
or you know multiple keys so i think we
can actually go into the code now and
see how we can implement this binary
search solution okay so now let's get
into the code and so you can see that
they already gave us like a class and a
few functions that we're going to define
so
the only thing we really need to do in
the constructor is just initialize our
store like i mentioned it's just going
to be a pretty simple hash map
where the key value is going to end up
being a string and the value of the
hashmap is going to be a list of lists
so
a list of pairs really but what we're
actually going to be using to implement
that pair is going to be yes a
another sub list and the values of that
sub-list are going to represent the
value itself which is going to be a
string and the second is going to be the
time stamp uh and yeah just uh kind of
condense this uh basically we're gonna
have a key that key is gonna be mapped
to a list of pairs okay so now let's get
into the set operation because it's a
little bit more simple than the get
operation the way i'm going to do this
is first just check so of course we're
inserting something based on this key
value based on this key and based on
this value based on this timestamp so
this is going to be that pair of value
timestamp and this is just going to be
the key of the hashmap first of all we
want to know does this key even exist in
our store and if it doesn't exist in our
store
the first thing we want to do is just
you know insert it into the store and
you know set it to let's say an empty
list so
put this key
and just set it to an empty list
you probably don't need to do this line
we could just use a default dictionary
if we really wanted to but i don't want
to abuse python too much because i think
sometimes it makes things too easy and
this would kind of be
i assume this is what you would want to
do if you were doing this in java or c
plus or something like that yeah so
after we have uh you know we know that
for sure we have an empty list there
then all we want to do is to that list
append a value to it right append to the
end of the list uh a pair of values the
value itself and the timestamp
associated with it and that's really it
right the set operation is pretty
straightforward in this case but the get
operation is where things are going to
get a little bit tricky so first i'm
just going to initialize the result
initially it's just going to be an empty
string and the reason i'm doing this is
because if this key doesn't even exist
in the store itself then this is what
they want us to return they just want us
to return an empty string that's why i'm
initializing it this way and the next
thing we want to do is actually check
what that list of values actually is so
let's go to our store and run the get
operation reason i'm using the get is
because if we find a match it'll return
that list if it doesn't find a match
with this key by default we can
tell it to just return an empty list
yeah so this is our list of values and
now is when we actually want to run the
binary search and then after we run the
binary search we're going to end up
returning whatever the result happens to
be as you may know
binary search has usually two pointers a
left and right pointer i have solved a
variety of binary search problems on
this channel i even have a binary search
playlist if you
want to practice uh but yeah so let's
set the left and let's get the length of
the array minus one is going to be our
right pointer and basically while the
left pointer hasn't crossed the right
pointer we are going to run the binary
search
actually should be equal if we want to
make sure to get the last value but yeah
so we have a left and right pointer and
usually we want to look at the middle
value so we can just take left plus
right divide it by two in in python
integer division you need two uh slashes
to do that otherwise it does decimal
division and
then we just want to know did we find
the result or not well if we found it
let's check in our values values at
index m and we know this is going to be
a pair of values we want to look at the
time stamp which is the second value up
above right you can see even in the
comments we said that the second value
is the timestamp so we can go to index
1. if this is equal to the timestamp
that we're searching for which was an
input parameter to this function called
timestamp actually instead of an exact
match let's first check if it's less
than the timestamp less than or even
equal to the timestamp because in that
case we know that it's a valid value
because remember the else case from this
is completely different than this one
right if it's equal to the timestamp or
less than the timestamp that's
completely fine but if it's greater than
the timestamp that value is not allowed
so we are going to be handling these two
cases a little bit differently so with
most binary search if we
if we know that this is less than the
timestamp what would we want to do we
would want to say the way we want to
update the pointer is to set left equal
to mid plus 1 because we want to search
to the right portion if it was less than
the result but before we do that even we
want to say the result so far at this
point right since this is a valid value
and this is the closest value we have
seen so far we are going to set the
result equal to values uh you know
basically the value at index m
and then you know this is going to be
index 0. right because this is the
closest we have seen so far that's how
this binary search is going to work this
is the closest we've seen so far now
let's go to the next iteration of the
loop and then see if we got any closer
to the result but the else case is going
to be
whoops the else case is going to be the
opposite here all we're going to do is
update the pointer if the value was too
big it was greater than the timestamp
which is what the else case is we would
want to update the right pointer set it
to mid minus one and then you know
that's just how we're going to be
searching but we're not going to assign
the result here because this is an
invalid value we cannot assign it to the
result technically this isn't as
optimized as it could be because you
know in this uh equals in the first case
if we even find the exact match to the
time stamp we're not even returning
right we're still continuing the binary
search which is kind of sub optimal but
it doesn't change the overall time
complexity it's still login and in this
case i kind of prefer the concise code
so i'm going to leave it as it is
because we are actually done with the
function after you know this binary
search is over we're going to go ahead
and return the result whether it's an
empty string or whether we actually
found the correct value
you know the closest value to that
timestamp that's the entire code let's
run it to make sure that it works
and as you can see on the left yes it
does work and it's pretty efficient
probably could be a little bit more
efficient if we actually returned when
we find the value but that's okay i hope
that this was helpful if it was please
like and subscribe it really supports
the channel a lot consider checking out
my patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching